time flies when you're having fun and
though it's hard to believe i've now
been putting videos up on this channel
for two whole years more than a thousand
videos
more than 5 000 subscribers and this
thing has become far bigger than i ever
predicted
now after big milestone i always think
it's kind of important to look back
take stock and think about what i've
learned in the last 12 months i think
the biggest thing i've discovered or
i should say rediscovered has definitely
been
make mistakes you know make mistakes and
don't be afraid
of making mistakes as a math teacher i
spend all day asking questions
many people think that you know teaching
is mainly about telling people what to
think
that's kind of true but more often i'm
asking questions and trying to draw
students toward articulating ideas and
developing skills themselves
and a long time ago very wise person
told me that the one doing the talking
is the one doing the learning
which is why peer teaching is so
important but
i'm getting sidetracked my point is that
i ask lots of questions every day
and so often i find students preface
their answers with a little phrase
and that phrase it breaks my heart every
time i hear it
the phrase is i'm not sure this is right
but look i'm exaggerating a little i'm
actually really glad that someone anyone
would be willing to stick their hand up
in class
even when they're not 100 confident
they're right that's awesome and
actually i'm really proud of my students
when they go out on a limb with an idea
and take a risk in front of their
friends i think that takes a lot of
courage and bravery and that's fantastic
right
but i think it'd say is it reveals
something really sad
about classroom culture and our society
in general
when we feel like we kind of need to ask
for permission before we say
something when we're not sure it's 100
right and kind of we're all like that
are we you know we put up our hand and
even though it's a very simple physical
action
it almost feels like in a classroom
there's this big uh
stage light sort of shining on us and
now everyone's looking at us and if we
get things
wrong then everyone will think we're an
idiot i think it's really sad
that our classrooms are like that and
that our society is like that
that there's so much uh expectation and
pressure
that we have to get things right and we
have to get them right first time
in fact it's when we get things wrong
it's when we make mistakes
and then analyze those and try and work
out why we did things wrong
that's when we actually learn so this
year as many of you know
i've been in a new role in a new school
and
i've been constantly every day multiple
times a day
thrust into unfamiliar situations and
i've made mistakes
and here's the important thing that i've
really discovered rediscovered
this year when you're under pressure
when you don't have enough time to get
everything done
when you're encountering a new situation
that's when you really
learn and it's important to put yourself
deliberately
into those situations getting outside
your comfort zone
is really hard if you're anything like
me then you've kind of spent your whole
life
running away from mistakes and there's
kind of this analogy that i really like
which is that everyone has a mistake
monster it's kind of like you know this
um little creature that's following us
around and we spend
you know so much of our effort trying to
flee from that monster
as if it's gonna you know pin us to the
ground and sort of eat our brains out
when it catches us
and we're very very like we're afraid
we're mortified
of making mistakes and making them in
front of other people but the reality is
that our mistake
monsters everyone's got one um is
actually if you can make it your friend
going to be a really valuable ally
because our mistake monsters they just
want to teach us they want us to help
they want to help us learn what's a good
way to do things what's an ineffective
way to do things
and why one things are one way or
another
if only we will learn to embrace our
mistakes and say well
okay i failed i'll work out why i failed
and i'll make sure that i don't do that
next time then that'll free us up to do
all kinds of different things that we
would just be too risk-averse and too
scared to ever attempt
there are always going to be people
around who dislike you getting things
wrong
is not only ourselves and our own desire
to always be seen as
you know getting things right and having
this wonderful self-image
but there will be maybe you know your
family or the people that you work with
or the people who supervise you
you're always going to interact with
some people who are very intolerant of
people making mistakes
but it's really up to you to settle for
yourself
the person who's really got to live with
your mistakes is you
and if you decide if you resolve to say
look i'm going to make mistakes in fact
i'm going to
attempt things and put myself in myself
in situations where
i know i'm going to do things wrong and
i'm going to have to pick myself up
then you're going to learn lots more
you're going to achieve a lot more
and that's going to be beneficial to you
and to everyone around you
so here's some homework for you i want
you to go away and have a careful think
to yourself
about something that you know you've
been thinking about doing you've been
seeing other people doing perhaps
but you've always kept yourself back
from because you're just too scared you
know you're gonna probably screw up and
you know you don't want to put yourself
in that situation you don't want to see
um other people recognize that you're
not perfect
that you can make mistakes think about
something like that
and resolve that you're going to give it
a go you're going to give it a shot
and if you mess up which you probably
will that's okay
you're going to pick yourself up you're
going to learn from that and you're
going to give it another shot
and you're going to keep on persevering
until you really master it
do it for yourself it's going to be
really valuable you're going to learn
tons from it
and your character will grow as well and
good luck